yesterday we had a very nice opening
ceremony in a outdoor pavilion but our
friend alejandro he was a magnificent
master of ceremonies as uh guys we had a
one of the better maybe the best i
thought i thought that was actually yeah
we've ever had generally i think you
know chess players and i still you know
kind of remember
the feeling that i was one at some point
dislike the genre because the the
opening ceremony generally happens like
on a day prior to around one right yeah
your thoughts are already in particular
here where the pairings are announced so
everybody knows what they're what
they're going to be doing the next day
and from for players the the you know
the thought process of trying to prepare
for that game has already begun right
and it kind of gets in the way the cymo
was so nice because the juniors all get
to play against their heroes you and i
may never get to play a novak djokovic
in a game of tennis but you can say i
played against
magnus carlsen and alireza ferrugia
they all had to gang up on me to beat me
up
but yeah you kind of interrupted me
there at a negative point
not the interruption but like the point
was unfortunate it looked like i was you
know slagging the the the opening i
thought that was linear size it was yeah
yeah but
what they did yesterday was just so nice
in so many ways that i think i think the
players couldn't possibly have minded
and uh yeah there was there was this uh
this simul five five players of the
tournament did and and then a very very
nice streamlined opening with speeches
by by rex and uh
and uh the other the person in charge of
the
forest park which was
very very nice
and
the whole ceremony is on youtube and
alejandro i thought the
the rap song about bobby fisher and 40
moves away was
brilliant it was very creative oh i
loved it it's so fun to see the
creativity here in st louis and i love
that we have this cooperation with the
world chess hall of fame there you saw
brian owens and his band
performing yesterday and it was great
how they're able to bring all of this
together to celebrate chess in so many
ways